They've won five out of six.
This ND team is getting hot.
What's coming together for them,
as they just knocked off
your Patriots on Saturday night.
Well, let me just tell you,
okay, because back when Tony
Dungy had these guys, they were
this finesse team. They're
going to pass the ball. They had
Peyton Manning. They're no
longer a finesse team like they
used to be.
All right, this offense really
sets the tone for this team
and those wide receivers,
whether
Pittman and Pascal. These guys
are big, they're physical. They
set the tone in the Run game.
They blocking to receive. I'm
to blocking a dbe's 20 yards
down the field Quinton else.
Um, he's healthier this offense
line is outstanding, but what
Baby, I, what I call him. I call
him a
call him. A, he's a smaller
version of Derrick, Henry, but
faster, you know, I mean, this
is what you get in Jonathan
Taylor. He's basically a smaller
version of Derrick,
Henry, but faster.
And I mean, he's the,
I mean, come on, man. This dude,
if anybody's probably should be
second in MVP, boat voting
behind
Aaron Rodgers. It should be this
guy. I mean he's come in
and he's established Frank
rights done a great deal
committing to running the
football taking the ball out of
Carson twins hands, but
This offense is physical and the
Colts are no longer
a finesse team. They're going to
run the ball down your throat.
And I'm going to tell you
something else.
They got a pretty good special
teams. All right, Raven, Trona
former teammate of mine. He's
their special teams
coordinator. And this is the top
special teams in the NFL
and they make a difference.
Every single week. This is
the number one special teams
team in the league and they make
a difference.
Every single week. They're
blocking upon
blogging. A field goal, you
know,
making a big return, they're
doing whatever they have.
To do Frank rice done. A great
job down there. We'll see what
happens with Carson Wentz in the
playoffs, but he's done
a great job.
He sure has it. He's taking a
team that got out of the gates
very slow and has developed them
in a loud environment with
everybody going. You got to get
rid of when it's this was
a mistake Reich sucks. And he's
just prepared this season on
the Fly and a big part of its
Clinton Nelson coming back. You
mentioned that offensive line
who I think deserves a ton of
credit all five of them fish are
Nelson, Pinter glow in ski
and Smith at. Right? Tackle has
been a top 10, right tackle.
All season long, but Jonathan
Taylor's over 1,500 yards. All
right, we still got three games,
left, 17 touchdowns. And
that's a big number 17
touchdowns on the ground, over
a hundred yards, five out of the
last six games over 150
yards.
Three out of the last six games.
So he's getting hot down
the stretch and with Tom Brady,
having a bad game, a really bad
game on Sunday night. It now
comes down to, I agree with
you. I think you got Aaron
Rodgers, and you got Jonathan
Taylor, and if we didn't
disrespect the running back
position, like we do in this
league,
in my opinion, it
Jonathan Taylor as the MVP.
Yeah, I mean think about them
but he is the most valuable
player to his team because
without sure and the Colts they
look totally different without
him on a field and you should
see the relief from the
defense's because now defenses
are afraid. They're like, oh my
God, I got to deal with Quentin
Nelson. I gotta deal with this
offensive line and I got a deal
with these big, physical wide
receivers blocking US. 20 yards
down the field and I got a date.
Trying to bring Jonathan
Taylor.
Got it runs for three at 230
pounds. And all he has to do is
give you a stiff arm. It's
tough, man. It's going to come
down a Someone's I like their
defense. They're not like super
physical.
They got linebackers that run
around kind of runaround from
sideline to sideline, Darius
Leonard. We know that he's
the top playmaking linebacker in
the NFL but it's going to come
down to Carson Wentz. And if
they struggle running
the football, because
they'll have nine guys on the
line of scrimmage. They're
going to force Carson, Wentz to
throw, throw the ball to beat
him and we'll see what happens.
It'll happen at some point.
We'll have to. And that defense
31 takeaways first in the NFL.
That's what they
do. Plus 14 turnover,
differential. That leads
the entire league by substantial
margins. That's how they've won
a bunch of these.